(audience claps)
We're here with best buds,
Casey Wilson
and Danielle Schneider.
(audience cheers)
Thank you.
And we have just had the best time.
You can look at the floor,
it pretty much shows
(cohosts laugh)
how we're rolling around here.
This story was really interesting to me.
Would you ever wonder what would happen
if "The Bachelorette"
and "Bridgerton" had a baby?
Well, Popsugar reports that
that's just what you'll get
in the newest dating show on NBC called "The Courtship".
A young single woman named Nicole Remy
will live in an old Regency-era castle
with a group of suitors who will try to woo her
with carriage rides, archery,
and handwritten love notes.
Nicole's real life parents will be there too,
to make sure the gentleman's intentions are good.
Casey, Danielle, please give us your thoughts.
Now, I'm a huge "Bridgerton" fan, huge.
Of course.
Yeah.
(audience applauds)
But I will say, like, these were like, dukes,
and real dukes
and duchesses we're dealing with,
and I don't know,
this is just gonna be some like, accountant from Paramus?
No offense.
Yeah.
(Drew laughing)
But I just kinda feel
like, you know, when you go home,
he's still that.
Yeah.
Exactly.
You know?
He's gonna be like, a dental hygienist from Rhode Island,
which is all fine,
but it's not quite the like,
dressed up look we're expecting, I think-
Yeah.
at the end of the day.
I want him in jodhpurs all the time.
Yes.
Right, you don't want
the fantasy to end.
No.
And yeah, when you get home
and you're on TikTok
and he's on "Fantasy Football", it's not,
remember when it used to be candle light?
Well that's 'cause you didn't have electricity, dear.
That's why it was romantic.
Casey, what's next?
Okay, so next up we have,
the New York Times reports
that this is the year of weddings.
Oh.
It's gonna be
complete "Bride Wars".
Favorite movie in the world.
Thank you so much,
I did write it with my friend, June Diane Raphael.
Anyway, it's gonna be completely bananas,
but by the end of 2022,
there will be over 2.5 million weddings
which is the most since 1984.
So the competition for venues
and vendors is making it so expensive
and difficult to plan, but it's also expensive for guests.
In 2019, guests spent an average
of $430 to attend a single wedding,
and this year the numbers are going up.
It's true.
I mean, can I just say, I'm terrified.
I have two weddings. I have to sell my house.
I can't do it.
(audience laughs)
I never really get invited to weddings.
I don't know why,
but I mean, I feel like I'm a good guest.
I'm a good time gal.
When I have a second wedding, if my marriage crumbles,
you are my first invite.
Thank you.
And I will get married just
to have you be in my wedding-
Thank you Danielle.
So my husband, he's gone.
Actually, I do have a wedding I'm going to this year.
I was just gonna say, I do think you have been invited
to one wedding this year.
I'm actually your flower girl right?
That's right, Miss Barrymore.
(audience applauds)
The first one.
So this year is looking up for me,
but as the like, birther of "Bride Wars",
what do you think about the fact that,
and it's interesting because they said "not since 1984",
which makes me do the math in my mind
and think, the reason the wedding industry actually changed
and there's all this data on it,
is because of Princess Diana's wedding.
Whoa.
And that fairytale wedding
like, changed the wedding industry.
And here we are, all this time later,
having a banner year, what do you think?
I mean, I think you're right.
It was the people's princess that changed us all
on a cellular level.
When I saw her with that long-
80 foot train.
Yes,
and I think also COVID.
Obviously, people are just trying
to scramble to get those venues.
Yeah, 'cause we couldn't.
We had to push things on pause for like two years
and now, you know, it feels like now's the time, honey.
Do it.
I guess what I'm really getting at is,
"Bride Wars 2022"-
Yes.
Is there a possibility-
(audience applauds)
of another movie, a prequel, a sequel, anything?
I'm on it.
I know someone who can star.
Hello.
Yeah.
And the other star.
We'll fight to the death.
We'll sort of
see how it goes.
Yeah, I mean,
look, we'll cast her first
and then see what happens next.
Yeah. We'll go from there.
When you say you're on it, I mean,
are you really gonna do it?
Could there be a reboot?
I'm gonna make it happen.
You know, I'm gonna go actually
and start.
(Ross laughs)
'Kay perfect.
Please get on that.
(upbeat pop music)